E
GET IT.
LET'S BRING IN FLORIDA
REPUBLICAN SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
TODAY YOU CAME OUT OF THIS
BRIEFING, YOU TOLD REPORTERS
THIS IS DANGEROUS, POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC AND COULD ESCALATE.
HOW SERIOUS IS THIS AT THIS
MOMENT?
>> WELL, THERE IS TWO THINGS,
RIGHT INVASION OF UKRAINE DEEPLY
PROBLEMATIC RETURNING TO A WORLD
IN WHICH POWERFUL COUNTRIES TAKE
OVER CHINA IS MAKING ALL THESE
STATES ARE SO THAT WOULD BE A
BIG DEVELOPMENT.
BUFF THE SECOND THING TO KEEP IN
MIND IN ALL OF THIS IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR MISCALCULATION AND
ESCALATION.
HAVE YOU GOT THE LARGEST RUSSIAN
MILITARY OPERATIONS GOING ON,
EXERCISES IN 35 OR 40 YEARS.
YOU HAVE GOT NATO COUNTRIES ON A
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF MILITARY
READINESS AND RIGHT CLOSE TO
EACH OTHER.
THERE IS ALWAYS THAT POTENTIAL.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE RUSSIAN ACTION IN
TERMS OF NAVIGATING CLOSE TO
SHIPS AND THINGS OF THIS NATURE
AND THEN SOME OF THE REPORTING,
INCLUDING THE BRITS.
SO THERE IS A LOT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND THEN THE NOTION OF CYBER
WARFARE.
IF PUTIN LAUNCHES CYBER WARFARE.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A CYBER WAR WE
DON'T KNOW HOW QUICKLY THAT
ESCALATES WHAT THAT CAN BECOME A
LOT TO WORRY ABOUT HERE IN TERMS
OF THIS THING ESCALATING BEYOND
UKRAINE.
>> Bret: SHOULD AMERICANS BE
CONCERNED ABOUT CYBER
RETALIATION IN SOME WAY, SHAPE
OR FORM FROM RUSSIA FOR EXAMPLE
IF CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SORT OF THING.
THE RUSSIANS RESPOND THAT WAY?
>> I THINK CYBER VULNERABILITY
SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF.
WE HAVE SEEN IT BECAUSE OF
CYBERCRIME AND RANSOMWARE.
THERE IS ALWAYS THE CONCERN
NATION STATE ADVANCED
CAPABILITY.
RUSSIA TODAY, CHINA TOMORROW
COULD LAUNCH SOME ATTACKS, THE
PROBLEM WITH CHINA THESE ARE NOT
PRECISE WEAPONS.
THEY ARE BLUNT INSTRUMENTS.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU CYBERATTACK A
SYSTEM YOU THINK THE OUTCOME AND
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE ONE THING
AND TURNS OUT TO BE SOMETHING
MORE SERIOUS.
OTHER COUNTRY HAS TO RESPOND AND
YOU START ESCALATING.
NO ONE HAS EVER CONDUCTED THIS
CYBER WARFARE BEFORE.
THERE IS NOT REALLY A DOCTRINE,
A RULES OF THE ROAD OR ANYTHING
THAT GOVERN IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE TWO
GOALS IN MIND THERE HAS TO BE
REAL CONSEQUENCE FORCE INVASION
OF URK.
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT ALLOW THIS
TO ESCALATE BEYOND UKRAINE INTO
SOMETHING BROADER.
>> Bret: HOW HAS THIS
ADMINISTRATION HANDLED THIS IN
YOUR OPINION?
HOW ABOUT COMING OUT PUBLICLY
AND SHARING WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT
POSSIBLE FALSE FLAG OPERATIONS
AND WHEN MAYBE PUTIN MIGHT MOVE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK TIME WILL TELL
ABOUT WHETHER THAT WORKED OR
NOT.
LOOK, IF THERE IS NOT AN
INVASION AND PUTIN IS PERSUADED
FROM INVADING THAT WOULD BE A
GREAT OUTCOME.
THAT'S ONE WAY TO GO ABOUT IT.
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN THAT WAY.
PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
OPINION ABOUT IT MY VIEW IS THAT
WHEN SOMETHING THIS BIG THAT
INVOLVES GLOBAL AND NATIONAL
SECURITY IS ENGAGED.
I THINK THE POLITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY IS GOING TO COME
LATER.
IF MISTAKES WERE MADE.
RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON TWO THINGS AS I SAID THERE
HAS TO BE CONSEQUENCES.
NOT AMERICAN TROOPS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SEND
AMERICANS TO FIGHT IN UKRAINE.
HAS TO BE REAL CONSEQUENCE FORCE
AN INVASION.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE
MANAGE THIS VERY CAREFULLY SO IT
DOESN'T ESCALATE INTO SOMETHING
FAR MORE DANGEROUS AND
POTENTIALLY CATASTROPHIC.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
>> Bret: TWO MORE QUICK THINGS.
YOU HEARD THE REPORT ON THE
DURHAM INVESTIGATION.
AND WHAT YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT
THAT SO FAR.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
I MEAN, IT'S SHOCKING TO ME THAT
THIS IS NOT RECEIVING MORE
COVERAGE IN THE PRESS.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THE SUNDAY
SHOWS MENTIONED IT.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IS NOT SIMPLY THE PROBE USING
DATA SCIENTISTS TO MAKE UP A
STORY AND LINKS BETWEEN TRUMP
AND RUSSIA BUT THE WHITE HOUSE.
APPARENTLY THERE WAS A PRIVATE
COMPANY THAT HAD A CONTRACT TO
MANAGE SERVERS FOR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THEY WERE
SHARING INFORMATION TO HELP
BUILD A NARRATIVE FOR A
POLITICAL OPERATION.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHY -- THIS IS
ALL PROVEN TRUE.
IT WOULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL SCANDALS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
IT WOULD BE A CRIME, NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT AND IT WOULD TELL YOU
WHY THESE PEOPLE THINK THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET AWAY
WITH IT BECAUSE THE MEDIA WILL
NOT REPORT ON IT DID THIS WAS
THE OTHER WAY.
THIS WAS A STORY ABOUT HOW THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN HAD HIRED SOME
DATA EXPERTS AND OTHERS TO GO
OUT THERE AND DO THIS TO A
PRESIDENT CLINTON, THIS WOULD BE
LIKE WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE AROUND HERE.
>> Bret: SENATOR, WE ARE
COVERING IT EXTENSIVELY.
WE ARE GOING TO ASK A DEMOCRAT
ABOUT IT AFTER THE BREAK.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAY WHY ARE
REPUBLICANS SEEMINGLY NOT AS
ALARMED ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
HANDLING OF DOCUMENTS COMPARED
TO WORRIES ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAILS?
BOTH FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER SANDY BERGER.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN DEUTSCH
SLAPPED WITH CRIMINAL PENALTIES
FOR MISHANDLING NATIONAL
SECURITY DOCUMENTS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE 15 BOXES DOWN
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE IS ALLEGATIONS OF FLUSHING
DOCUMENTS DOWN THE TOILET IN THE
OVAL OFFICE THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS DENIED.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S TRUE AND WHAT'S NOT.
THEY HAVE MADE UP SO MANY
STORIES ABOUT DONALD TRUMP OVER
THE YEARS.
THINGS THAT I KNEW WERE FLAT OUT
UNTRUE.
NOW ADAYS IN MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
YOU NEED ONE SOURCE TO SMEAR
DONALD TRUMP.
MANE YOU DON'T EVEN NEED THAT
HARD TO TELL ANYMORE WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT DIDN'T.
THE DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO BY
ALL ACCOUNTS WERE TURNED OVER.
LOOK IF THE PROCESS WASN'T
FOLLOWED THERE, THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS.
NOT A CRIME I DON'T BELIEVE.
THE STUFF ABOUT FLUSHING PAPER
DOWN THE TOILET.
WHO KNOWS IF THAT IS EVEN TRUE.
AT THIS POINT I HAVE SEEN AT
LEAST A DOZEN THINGS SAID ABOUT
TRUMP THAT TURNED OUT TO BE
COMPLETE LIES.
MAKE IT UP AND SOME IN THE MEDIA
HAVE RUN WITH IT BOOKS THINGS IN
THERE THAT I KNOW WERE NOT TRUE
AND WIDELY WORD ROFTED A ADD
ESTABLISHED FACTS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO
TAKE ANYTHING THEY SAY SO
SERIOUSLY.
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT WITH WHAT
HAPPENED WITH CLINTON.
THAT'S NOT SOME REPORTER OR SOME
STORY IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
THAT'S A FEDERAL PLEADING IN
FEDERAL COURT.
>> Bret: SENATOR RUBIO, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.